[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this book is very much a conversation
it's very much a conversation between
phil and i
talking about
these characters and
what we think
it is about them that is so iconic and
what makes them resonant today it is my
understanding this is the first time
a history of her people has been
explored through the voice of a female
author through the voice of a woman and
i was sort of stunned by that
and again working with this particular
woman on this cast of women is what made
this um seem special
and elevated at the end of the day we
wanted to read like a history book for a
young amazon
who is learning about the history of her
people the same way any child is taught
the history of their their state or
their city or their country from the
perspective of their people
there's this amazing thing that happens
when you're working together on a book
it's a collaboration like i said i i
describe this book so much as a
conversation and it's very much a
conversation between phil and i and
there are other really important people
who are a part of the book but at the
core at the center of it is
you know he and i talking about these
things that
these questions and these ideas and
these these things that are so important
to both of us and you know he brings
such incredibly deep knowledge about
wonder woman and
her history and her world and he's such
an incredible artist
i've never had a relationship with my
writers in the way that i have with
kelly sue i look back in my career and
i'm actually maybe a little melancholy
about that but at the same time i'm
thinking
that this is an incredible gift that's
magical to me because it's the sort of
relationship in comics i've never had
before
what's different about this is when i
wrote and drew wonder woman 20 years ago
aside from being younger
it was just a very interesting time in
comics i've told this story many times
but i was essentially a glorified
villain artist for a year that ended up
having a run that people
look back with fondness what i have now
i think is a is honestly it's a it
sounds
heavier than i intend but it's um it's a
different understanding of the world
it's a different understanding
as much as i can in this body of women
about how women navigate the world of
how we fetishize
perfection in women like the amazons for
a long time had represented a perfect
people and one of the wonderful
conversations kelly and i had was about
unfair burden think about women as
people think about the amazons as people
i've clearly grown as an artist i did
almost the entirety of this work in
pencil and then on procreate on my ipad
so this was my first primary digital
work which is a reason it took me a long
time to get started because i needed to
get used to working digitally and i
think the effects speak for themselves
i'm very very fond of what i call the
pope harrah spread
which is just her standing
on olympus surrounded by all her birds
and peacocks the second is i did a
spread of the queens of the amazons
and i'm very very fond of the art on
that spread i like the design work i
like
the actual technical approach i think
there's some beautiful special effects
that i could never recreate again they
were all accidents and so
they're they're quite lovely on the page
what we we refer to as the vanity fair
spread it is the 30 original amazons the
30 amazons that are that are born
from the goddess's original mission it
looks like a vanity fair spread these
are all
powerful women
but some but the power is expressed
so differently in in each of their
bodies i don't know if it's even
possible because
of the amount of
work that would be involved in the
number of people that would be involved
but i am living to see
a cosplay of that of the 30. i would
like to see that recreated by 30
exceptional
women in a cosplay thing and it would be
the most magical day ever
[Music]
you